he's really depends right he invented
this feel this whole field of maths to
try and solve this problem
imogen he said look it doesn't it
doesn't matter if what you got is
changing you can still you can still
think about how it changes if you throw
a little bit of imagination so here's
what he said he's a different function
but it's just like our gravity now if I
take two points under I can still do the
same rise and run thing okay [ __ ] you
for that in a little different way I'll
show you why
usually we think of these points every
single there's one point x1 x2 y2 okay
and so what about the gradient what did
you do have you so you can send
different coordinates for the two points
because you wanted to muck around it
didn't change them okay so x1 y1 x2 y2
very random out trip so you said look
let's call this the first point X and
imagine I go forward at a distance H
it's a without G dagger
if I started X I gotta forward page
what will the x value of the next
birthday so be X plus y plus h this is
gonna give you gold run right before do
that oh no prizes as well okay now I
said look at the code function let's
just pull it matters all I do is I can
use it on any function if it's at best
then when I think about where these are
vertically so I can try and work out
arise okay run say of y1 which is just
arbitrary disconnected to x1 I can say
this is next and how much should I be
I should be f of X in the same way for
the next corner well experts page I
should be f of X plus h so whatever this
is I'll put into the function without
give me my wife oh my plans okay
so now we can approach it in the same
way as we've done it before rise over
run he said look if you imagine a
straight line that join these two points
you don't get to get exactly the
vibrating but we're pretty close like it
looks like it's about the same at least
you're the same walk okay so he said
look the gradient which he denoted with
a - they said what a one he said that's
what's approximately equal to rise over
run of this straight line it's not the
same but it's close so what's why's
everyone Rises this this is my Y - my y1
rise
yeah and then I'm dividing by run which
is this in fact it's just that distance
H right so this is just it's just they
said that'll get you close let me get
you close
well I would be better because I want to
be precise
okay I want to consider what if it
wasn't like a sketch of an interview
what if we could take this H and maybe
infinitesimally small okay so these
points were always sitting one on top of
another then I wouldn't be approximate
then I would actually be equivalent
all right so say look this thing this F
dash is rated right I'll be equal to
that if I can make this thing for two
points that are really many
infinitesimally close together so we
introduce this idea
so this idea this topic is actually not
just called calculus it's going to
limits and cocktails this idea of a
litter was Newton's breakthrough okay
because he realized that these two
points I can actually imagine the moving
closer and closer in question to each
other I can imagine this page not
equally zero because they need extra
points but approaching it getting very
very close so you said as H gets to that
it will approach a limits that's okay
it'll push an actual number now you can
see I can't just let H equal zero is
then you're dividing by zero but if I
not actually consider an example okay I
can actually work with